prosecutors want a former student from
Korea to return to the u.s. to face an
involuntary manslaughter charge after
her college boyfriend died by suicide
they allege in Jung you encouraged him
to take his own life
Alexander or Tula died in Boston on his
graduation day back in May police say
the case focuses on text messages his
girlfriend sent him and it's drawing
comparisons to another upsetting case in
Massachusetts mola legi is at Boston
College that's where the couple went to
school so molo good morning what else do
we know
well good morning Tony prosecutors say
that this is a case of domestic violence
they claim that miss you engaged in a
quote utter attack on her boyfriend's
will conscious and psyche and did so
mostly over text message and they say
that she was even tracking his movements
on her phone and that she was there when
he died miss you was physically verbally
and psychologically abusive toward mr.
or Toula during their 18-month long
relationship Suffolk County District
Attorney
Rachel Rollins claims 21 year-old in
young you encouraged her boyfriend
Alexander or Tula to kill himself
thousands of times abuse became more
frequent and more powerful in the days
and hours leading up to mr. or Tula's
untimely death according to prosecutors
the Boston College students exchanged
75,000 text messages in the two months
leading up to her Tula's death 47,000 of
those texts allegedly came from you and
included messages like go kill yourself
and go die many of the messages clearly
display the power dynamic in the
relationship the District Attorney's
Office says you was aware of her Tula's
spiraling depression and suicidal
thoughts brought on by her abuse she's
now facing one charge of involuntary
manslaughter it's the same charge in the
same state that sent his shell Carter to
jail after she was found guilty for the
2014 suicide of her friend Conrad Roy
Massachusetts prosecutors alleged Carter
relentlessly encouraged the teen to kill
himself over text her attorneys are
appeal
her convictions to the US Supreme Court
this indictment would not have been
filed if it were not for the Michelle
Carter case but CBS News legal analyst
Ricky Clements says this case is
different because of its international
scope the fact that the defendant is in
South Korea is going to make this case
much more complicated if she wants to go
through the process of contesting
extradition it could take years to get
her here the District Attorney's Office
here says that she is cautiously
optimistic that you will voluntarily
return from South Korea back here the
United States to face that involuntary
manslaughter charge if she does not they
say that they will seek extradition as
CBS News has been unsuccessful in
tracking down use attorney in South
Korea Anthony such a disturbing story
Imola thank you